I come from the land down under he
doesn't I was conceived in Australia on
my parents honeymoon it was a a romantic
Summer Night their summer on a blanket
in the park I still have that blanket
Phil's mom left us money for a trip
there when the rest of the family found
out they all just jumped on board my
mom's grandfather was Australian and
she'd spend her Summers their Winters
visiting him it was a very special place
for her she always wanted me to see it
right you still have that blanket yeah
silly it's the one on our bed
you sure you don't want some of this
Vegemite Gloria you don't know what
you're missing yeah I don't need
anything unless I know what's in it I've
seen this woman scarf down a pig's nose
sometimes one must travel halfway across
the globe to get the clearest view of
home this was my whole flight what's she
talking about my college application I
think they want students who are
worldlife oh why don't you write about
our trip to Hawaii when you drink
straight from the coconut I feel like
Harvard's gonna get a lot of those so
hey guys I just wanted to say thanks for
being a part of this pilgrimage to
Majestic Australia which was once a
penal colony
grow up this place was really special to
my mom she actually left me a list of
things that she thought we should do
visit the Great Barrier Reef see the
bush really and climb the Sydney Harbor
Bridge
what do you say mate I'm sorry honey but
you know how I am with Heights eyes that
way you never wear high heels
you guys are with me right absolutely no
I'm not doing that really no oh no
worries that's Australian I'll uh I'll
do that one on my own if I have to I'm
just so excited we're all here together
I just feel bad that Claire and Jay are
missing such a beautiful day in this
gorgeous country which is also a
continent you have a lot of fun uh-huh I
think this spiritual journey of yours is
a wonderful thing I think it's gonna
make you feel closer to your mother I
hope so I miss her
the biggest reason I came here to
connect
is that weird not at all I talked to my
leg grandmother all the time she would
have loved this place
I wonder if she's here with me now
she doesn't like to fly
it's been a while that my mom and dad
made Footprints and it's very sad what
[Applause]
are you okay yeah I'm fine I just wish
Claire was here to see all this uh of
course my foot's twice as normal size
and mosquitoes are really going after my
jellyfish bites oh look a sign
you wanted to see a kangaroo and now you
see one I think this is your mother time
to tell you that the rest of the trip is
going to be magical feel I saw my mom to
say it was a kangaroo look
s so beautiful okay but be careful
you're gonna scare him
g'day mate
there are you going
oh damn it
why Australia why
hey mate how's it going everything okay
here oh really
you don't mind me saying you look a bit
beaten up yeah
I love your country but your country
doesn't love me back
Australia's rejected me
you see this right here
that's from a Croc bite
this one hit on my back
I was hit by a tram in Melbourne
this right here
that's an irregular mole
should probably get that checked out
point is Australia is nice to tourists
but it's tough on its own people
congratulations mate you're one of us
are you saying what I think you're
saying well I think I am I'm crocodile
dunfee that's not what I was saying at
all
is that a kookaburra which you're born
blind or
[Music]
thank you